foreign
Now new and fascinating developments
tonight in the Biden open borders crisis
as failing D.C mayor Muriel Bowser she's
now claiming that illegal immigrant
illegal immigrants are crowding D.C
homeless shelters she's upset about it
and she claims they're being tricked
into hopping on buses to our nation's
capital she's upset about it take a look
this is a very significant issue we have
for sure called on the federal
government to work across state lines to
prevent people from really being tricked
into getting on buses we we think
they're largely Asylum Seekers who are
going to final destinations that are not
Washington D.C I worked with the White
House to make sure that FEMA provided a
grant to a local organization that is
providing services to folks but I fear
that they're being tricked into
Nationwide bus trips when their final
destinations are places all over the
United States of America
translation she doesn't want them in our
nation's capital you might remember
Texas governor Greg Abbott he's been
standing up to Biden's border disaster
and lawlessness and yuppies busting the
migrants right to Biden's doorstep in
D.C now maybe Muriel Bowser will now get
a glimpse of what border communities in
South Texas have been dealing with every
single day and the Texas governor and
every other border state Governor needs
to now do the same thing bust every
single illegal immigrant aided and
abetted by Joe Biden who's not enforcing
federal law and send them right out to
Washington D.C send them all to
Washington D.C here with reaction author
of battle for the American mind which is
still on the New York Times bestseller
list our friend Pete hegseth also landed
number one on the list and of course uh
former Trump of a treasury official
Monica Crowley Pete I love it she's
saying we don't want them it's too
expensive and then she added on top of
that she goes and by the way no local
local taxpayers should not be forced to
pay the bill for this uh every other
border state has been paying the bill
and dealing with this problem because
Joe Biden is aiding and abetting the law
breaking
and right after that sentence Sean she
said we need a coordinated Federal
response you think maybe on our border
to protect that border you know I've
been wanting Greg Abbott to declare an
invasion which gives constitutionally
the state of Texas additional powers and
I downplayed what he was doing on
bussing illegals to D.C I think I was
wrong on that the cumulative effect of
the amount of people who've landed in DC
heck let's send them to Delaware as well
and they're not being tricked they're
being asked they're volunteering to go
to Washington DC as a result now they're
flooded and swamped and she's admitting
what we always knew about Big City
leftist elitist oh you know this we we
welcome migrants and illegals as long as
they're in someone else's backyard not
ours they're they're flooding our
services what do you think Texas and
Arizona and New Mexico and Oklahoma what
do you think those states are facing
it's one of the best examples we've seen
yet of the complete double standard they
live in she just she said it on TV for
us yeah it's it's to me it's the perfect
strategy because it's the only thing
that has finally gotten a democrat's
attention so I think we institutionalize
it and I agree with Pete's point on the
Declaration for governor Abbott uh uh
Monica but I think we ought to send
everyone as a matter of fact I think
Texas you know to suck it up give every
illegal immigrant getting on that bus an
incentive maybe 50 bucks per person so
that when they get to D.C at least they
have maybe they get a good night's sleep
get some food and enjoy the beautiful
Capital uh LED under D.C mayor Bowser
I would add Sean to the 50 bucks I would
also give each of them directions to
Nancy Pelosi's home Muriel Bowser is
home uh the White House Capitol Hill so
they can go Monica now you're doxing
like the left is doxing Supreme Court
Justices you want to give out the
addresses of elected officials
well you know apparently the White House
and AOC and other Democrats are
perfectly fine with that so this is
their rules right Sean we're playing by
their rules they they laid it out so
we're going to play the same game look I
the the border states like Texas and
Arizona have had it with the invasion
this is a criminal Invasion not just of
those States but of the entire country
and those governors have decided that
they've had enough their people have had
enough they've borne the brunt of the
criminal activity The Invasion the
cartels the influx of drugs like
fentanyl into those States and they're
saying we're enough so we're going to
now inflict the consequences of
Washington DC's actions on to those in
Washington D.C by dumping them right on
the doorstep I would actually take it a
step further Governor Ron DeSantis has
actually talked about if any of those
illegals come to Florida he's going to
move them to Delaware and dump them on
the street of Joe Biden's house or Ted
Cruz idea which is ship them them to
Martha's Vineyard and put them on Barack
Obama's front lawn you will see the
Democrats switch gears like that because
you know what Sean the biggest split in
the country is between the ruling class
and everybody else the ruling class that
makes all of these catastrophic
decisions that the rest of us have to
live with and those governors and those
border states are are saying enough and
I think it's long past time and good for
them all right yes or no I'll ask both
of you the same question because
liberals for example on money and
financial issues they're always generous
with other people's money taxpayer money
what about a liberal adopt an asylum
Seeker program that that we could maybe
as conservatives fund for liberals and
they can adopt an asylum Seeker that's
in the country illegally and they can
live with them starting with Nancy
Pelosi and Chuck Schumer and Company
would that be a good idea Pete
uh yes tell me where to send the money
Sean
okay well with all the books you're
selling being number one on the New York
Times you're rich now so uh you'll have
plenty uh Monica last word
yeah yeah no look I agree it's time that
those of us who are bearing the brunt of
all of these catastrophic policies
mirror the other side and make them live
with the consequences that they're
inflicting on the rest of us this is
like Divine Justice all of a sudden it
happens to them uh the first reaction is
we this is outrageous we can't have this
we need to stop this we can't afford to
pay for this uh you pay for this this is
what Texas Arizona all these border of
states have been dealing with uh guys
good to see about Pete congrats on the
book